artem lâché bonjour merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france alors
tout d'abord est ce que vous aussi vous
craignez l'arrivée d'une seconde vague à
la fin de l'été non moi je suis plutôt
optimiste dans la mesure où on sait
qu'on a une mesure qui fonctionne très
bien que le port du masque dans l'est
dans les lieux clos
je pense pas que cette mesure est encore
montré la totalité de son efficacité je
pense qu'elle n'est pas encore
parfaitement appliquées je pense qu'il
ya encore des trous dans la raquette en
particulier avec les lieux
professionnels
en revanche je pense qu'on a tous les
éléments aujourd'hui pour être capable
de reprendre une activité en évitant
cette seconde vague
même si on n'a pas été extrêmement bon
entre le déconfinement et le la mesure
du port du masque obligatoire dans les
lieux chauds alors justement à paris
emboîté le pas à certaines capitales
européennes et grandes villes françaises
en rendant le port du masque obligatoire
à l'extérieur dans les lieux les plus
fréquentés c'était une mesure nécessaire
à votre avis non je pense qu'on fait là
on s'est trompé encore une fois de deux
cibles
on doit s'intéresser à landreau ce sont
les contaminations c'est à dire les
endroits clos les endroits où l'air
n'est pas renouvelé ou donc la charge
virale en suspension dans l'air est
suffisamment importante pour infecter
les personnes et c'est de là que
viennent les contaminations et donc ça
veut dire qu'en encore dans les lieux
clos il ya je disais des trous dans la
raquette se tourner vers l'extérieur
c'est une mauvaise stratégie donc non
seulement ça ça embête les gens puissent
qu'on a au mois d'août il fait 40 degrés
les gens sont obligés de porter des
masques et ça détourne l'attention du
vrai sujet qui est soit les
rassemblements familiaux soient les
lieux professionnels en huis clos où là
il faut mettre des règles strictes en
particulier aussi pour préparer la
rentrée de septembre pour faire en sorte
qu'on puisse totalement reprendre avec
des règles claires qui nous permette
d'avoir suffisamment confiance dans le
fait qu'on peut reprendre l'activité
complètement le taux d'incidence a
grimpé de 33% c'est à dire que le virus
circule on sait que ce sont les jeunes
qui sont de plus en plus touchés la
période estivale qui est propice aux
rassemblements et aux déplacements est
en cause
est-ce qu'il fallait mettre plus de
restrictions
non non je pense pas qu'il fallait
mettre plus de restrictions et la
circulation chez les jeunes
contrairement à ce qu'on entend à
beaucoup d'endroits c'est plutôt une
bonne nouvelle je donc il ya une
circulation virale qui est plus
importante avec une incidence qui monte
en partie parce que vous faites plus de
tester en partie parce que effectivement
les poteaux siens dynamique positive de
circulation du virus
al'inverse on a rien à l'hôpital ça veut
dire que pour l'instant la circulation
se fait chez les jeunes qu'elle est
relativement indolore pour l'ensemble de
la population la question qui va se
poser c'est est ce qu'on va voir des
patients qui vont arriver à l'hôpital en
août c'est à dire ce qu'on aura le virus
qui sera un petit peu passées dans les
populations vulnérables c'est ce que
nous allons voir et j'espère vraiment
que non et ça monte la deuxième mesure
qui est particulièrement importante
c'est la protection de la population
vulnérable pour l'instant ça fonctionne
très bien donc c'est plutôt une bonne
nouvelle
voilà je pense que pour l'instant la
seule chose qu'on peut regretter c'est
pas d'avoir porté les masses dans les
lieux clos suffisamment tôt mais ça a
pas l'air d'avoir eu un impact qui pour
l'instant de catastrophique donc je
pense qu'il faut perfectionner cette
mesure ne sera capable de reprendre une
rentrée sereine est l'arrivée de
l'automne et l'hiver et surtout un
propice à
voilà plusieurs virus il ya la grippe
est hyper d'autres maladies que l'on
peut constater souvent les symptômes se
ressemblent est-ce qu'il faudra tester
davantage la population française alors
je pense pas qu'il va falloir tester
davantage qu'aujourd'hui on teste
beaucoup d'ailleurs n'importe qui les
gens ce test qu'ils aient des signes
qu'ils aient un risque ou pas donc on
est déjà dans une stratégie on teste
énormément je pense qu'on fera les tests
différemment c'est à dire que oui
effectivement chaque personne qui aura
des symptômes pour le coup faudra
absolument faire le test pour pouvoir
identifier si c'est un ca reçoivent 2 ou
si c'est un vrai souci c'est un virus de
la grippe donc ça ça va faire qu'il va
falloir faire des prises en charge des
patients qui sont à différentes mais je
pense simplement qu'on fera les tests
différentes comme vous faites bien de
rappeler l'automne effectivement peut
être un facteur d'accélération pour
plusieurs raisons déjà il va faire plus
froid donc c'est plutôt quand même un
facteur qui favorise qui est favorable
au virus
en plus les gens vont retourner au
travail dans des lieux clos et puis va
faire plus froid les gens seront moins
extérieur dans tous ces facteurs là font
que ce sont plutôt des facteurs
stimulants la circulation du virus est
encore une fois je vous dirais des
mesures très efficaces dans les lieux
clos et donc c'est pour ça qu'il faut
aller mettre en place et est assez clair
là dessus
et à ce moment là on pourra reprendre
nos activités sans avoir peur de cette
seconde vague en partie de cette seconde
vague d'hospitalisation pour les
personnes les plus vulnérables à être
vigilant et bien appliquée à tous les
gestes barrière et le port du masque en
tout cas merci beaucoup martin havlat
chez d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes épidémiologistes
et médecin de santé publique
[Applaudissements]